dans cette entrée
l'accusé on disait
un bon fait divers c'était du sang du
sperme et un doute
l'affaire Grégory Xavier Dupont Ligonnès
nordah Lelandais ou plus récemment
Leslie et Kevin les faits divers font
partie de notre quotidien et ses
affaires criminelles passionnent des
millions de Français alors pourquoi
l'effet divers nous passionne t-il
autant
[Applaudissements]
dans la nuit du 25 au 26 novembre 2022
un couple disparaît dans les Deux Sèvres
plusieurs semaines plus tard les corps
de Leslie et Kevin sont retrouvés un
fait divers banal qui devient tout d'un
coup médiatique la question de savoir
quand est-ce que ça devient aussi un
vrai fait divers c'est aussi quand il y
a un rebondissement et là en
l'occurrence il y a eu un rebondissement
puisque un proche de de Leslie et Kevin
qui était depuis le début de l'affaire
très actif dans les recherches qui avait
participé à une battue citoyenne qui
partageait la vie de la vie de recherche
en fait a été mis en examen pour
enlèvement et séquestration autre
caractéristique du bon fait divers
l'identification la première chose qui
fait que les gens s'intéressent au crime
c'est
est-ce que moi je pourrais être invité
où est-ce que moi c'est encore plus mal
pensons est-ce que je pourrais être
auteur
et ces deux jouets avec ces deux
terreurs qui fait que les gens
s'intéressent aux cris nous l'avons vu
récemment avec l'affaire Palmade on en a
tous discuté à un moment ça a été un
sujet de conversation dans de nombreux
endroits le fait divers est un créateur
de lien social il y a une question
effectivement de rassemblement c'est pas
uniquement je dirais c'est pas du
voyeurisme morbide le fait divers ça
appartient propre aux propres de l'homme
de s'interroger sur ce sur ce qui était
étrange malgré l'omniprésence médiatique
des faits divers il est difficile de s'y
habituer il est difficile d'y être
insensible surtout quand le drame
concerne des enfants je dirais que le
propre de l'homme et de la femme enfin
de l'humanité c'est quand même de
protéger ses enfants c'est de protéger
notre descendance et quand un enfant est
tué d'une façon ou d'une autre dans un
fait divers alors là ça nous touche au
plus profondément donc ce sont ceux-là
qui depuis toujours on fait la plus
grande audience en ce qui concerne les
faits divers on va dire criminel dans
les médias des émissions spécialisées
dans les affaires criminelles mais on
fait accentuer notre fascination c'est
notamment le cas de Faites entrer
l'accusé
[Musique]
nous avons peut-être notre part parce
que moi je n'étais que le présentateur
un produit complexe produit à plusieurs
mais nous avons peut-être votre part de
responsabilité nous avons
réconcilier le genre avec le journalisme
et peut-être que nous avons semé une
graine qui a mal poussé qui partaient de
travaux
c'est possible mais reconnaissons que ça
n'était pas notre intention puisque nous
n'avons jamais traité d'histoire en
cours nous n'allons jamais traité de
dossier non élucidé nous n'avons traité
que de dossiers juger et rejet s'il y
avait à peine à l'été 2020 le magazine
Society publie deux numéros consacrés à
Xavier Dupont Ligonnès plus de 450 000
exemplaires sont vendus en streaming les
documentaires et les séries criminels
cartonnent et cette fascination pour les
faits divers n'est pas nouvelle on
raconte que à Rome il y avait des riches
romains qui envoyaient leurs esclaves se
promener dans les marchés pour qu'il
rapporte ou qu'il rapporte les choses
curieuses qui s'était passé donc
aujourd'hui on a plus de riches esclaves
mais on a la télévision la radio les
réseaux sociaux qui nous expliquent
toutes les choses étranges qui se
passent dans le monde et qu'on ne
comprend pas un appétit de faits divers
difficile à combler impossible de tout
raconter jour après jour heure après
heure
en gros une enquête criminelle entre la
découverte du corps et de la comparution
devant une cour d'assises en moyenne il
s'écoule 4-5 ans et les journalistes
voudraient en rendre compte tous les
jours
il y a une incapacité à marcher au même
rythme entre les journalistes et les
juges et cette course à l'information
peut parfois être précipitée
à dire une chose un jour mais son
contraire le lendemain c'est dans
l'affaire Palma de ça a été un spectacle
absolument désolant
un jour blanc le lendemain noir et
quelque part ce sentiment que chez eux
ça me pose aucun problème puisque que ce
soit blanc ou noir ça fait deux
informations aujourd'hui on tourne un
peu en rond plus les gens s'intéressent
aux faits divers plus ils sont traités
dans les médias et forcément plus ils
sont traités dans les médias plus les
gens s'y intéressent